[Musique]
celui qui enchaîne les figures ou tricks
c'est antoine ça c'est pour ses potes
pour les skateurs du monde entier il est
angie le kid passer des spots orléanais
à la première marche du podium
je suis monté là dessus je m'en donnais
mon trophée gt gt j'étais content mais
je rêve réalisé mais j'ai pas au fait
c'était vide quoi donc mon cerveau
j'étais juste content
eindhoven aux pays bas en novembre
dernier antoine participe à un contest
international une compétition dans le
jargon et le voilà a à peine 20 ans
propulsé champion du monde de longboard
dancing
je suis beaucoup plus motivés qu'avant
notamment pour les prochaines éditions
les voilà pour les prochains conteste
même les plus petits conteste quoi là
c'est ça m'a motivé je sais de quoi je
suis capable entre guillemets j'aimerais
maintenant maintenir ce niveau là et
pourquoi pas gagner d'autres d'autres
contestent quoi la longboard une planche
qui mesure entrant m et 1 mètre 50 ans
toit de la découverte il ya à peine cinq
ans et ça a été une révélation
j'ai vu un mec faire du lambon fois à
orléans j'ai vu ça je me suis dit mais
en fait c'est nouveau moi j'avais jamais
vu ça nulle part je me suis dit c'est
nouveau c'est esthétique c'est moins
entre guillemets bourrin que le skate
quoi c'est plus artistique et j'ai tout
de suite accroché avec ça ça s'appelle
un petit arpent une pirouette
et ben voila en gros une line classique
de longboard dancing c'est ce que je
vais le faire commencer par des petits
pas de danse et finir avec un tricks
quoi
pour atteindre ce niveau il s'entraîne
deux à quatre heures par jour plus de
dix heures 6 et avant une compétition
c'est party game of skate je commence
comme souvent il est rejoint par thomas
son ami d'enfance qu'il a rapidement vu
évoluer avant d'exceller se fierté
d'avoir un ami
comment dire qu'à dépasser ses limites
qui réalisait son rêve qui a atteint ses
objectifs aujourd'hui m'apportes il a un
tremplin un tremplin monstrueux pour
l'avenir est juste que du bonheur boosté
par son petit trait appuyé par plusieurs
sponsors antoine a choisi d'arrêter ses
études en langues étrangères pour se
consacrer pleinement à sa passion
moi j'aimerais faire du longboard toute
ma vie enfin tant que j'en suis capable
quoi et quand je ne serai plus capable
ou quand j'en aurai plus envie si j'en
ai plus envie un jour mener des projets
tout autour de ça vous m'avez fait
confiance on est derrière lui on le
soutient et on voit bien qu'on a eu
raison parce qu'il arrive à faire
quelque chose de grand et avec plusieurs
projets professionnels à la clé donc
c'est vrai que ça nous a compromis lui
rassuré en plus c'est très très fier on
a été rassuré là dessus
sitôt obtenu six taureaux mis en jeu à
cause d'un calendrier bousculé par le
cos vide antoine devra se battre pour
conserver son titre dès le 16 avril
prochain